good morning ladies and gentlemen
a warm welcome to the design track in
tech innovation 2020
i'm mark the executive director of
design singapore council
and thank you ipi for inviting us back
again to the tech innovation conference
this year's theme is about catalyzing
innovation with design
but can design actually be a catalyst
for innovation
and what exactly does design mean
well a study by the design management
institute in 2016
shown that design-led companies deliver
on average more than
200 percent returns over the s p
500 than non-design-led companies
so what exactly are these design-led
companies doing differently
and again what does design mean well
if steve jobs put it aptly design is
more than just making things look pretty
it's actually about making things work
and in fact it is a key to problem
solving and innovation
innovating this process is now known as
design thinking
design-led companies use design to
create value and unlock
innovation and opportunities and for
successful innovation and transformation
to take place you need
these three elements to be in place
first
technological feasibility second
justifiability and third market
desirability
a good design-led process enables an
organization to bring these three
elements together
in order for innovation to take place
and this process also needs to be
underpinned by great empathy for
your user needs and their experience
with your product
service or experience
well actually now here's a great example
of how a company
leveraged design to propel innovation in
nike
nike has actually completely reinvented
its true manufacturing process
and rather than setting out to design a
new show the company designed a new way
to conceptualize
the manufacturing of an athletic shoe
itself
nike's designers pioneered the new nike
flyknit technology to deliver a peak
performance shoe
for athletes in a sustainable way it
actually took them 195
tries using the reinvented manufacturing
process before the
flyknit racer was actually born and i
was assured as
was more environmentally friendly and
reduced wastage by
some 80 as compared to other traditional
nike footwear
such as the power of using design and
design thinking
where you start with how you can make
your products or services better for
your customers
and then balancing that out with
technological and business viability
this is also what we at design singapore
strive to do
and that is helping businesses adopt
design and design thinking
as a key enabler for them to drive
profitable and desirable human-centered
innovation
design singapore is actually the
national agency for design in singapore
our vision is to help singapore become
an
innovation driven economy and a loveable
city designed
by design by 2025 and we are constantly
working
closely with the industry design
consultants and both
public and private sector to help drive
business transformation through the use
of design
recognizing the importance of designing
technological innovation our partner ipi
invited us to helm an inaugural design
track at last year's
tech innovation conference and this
session was very well received by the
tech community
and we invited prominent design
professionals and practitioners
to share
and this year we are bringing you two
plenaries one on sustainability
and the other on smart and livable
cities each plenary is connected by
three prominent speakers
pioneers in their own fields in the
space of design and innovation and we
are honored to have them grace
today's session we've also added two new
segments in this year's design track
the design runway and the design think
tank
and much like ipi's crowd pitching and
crowd sourcing
but for designers and for solutions
primed at using design
so we hope you'll have a fruitful
session of great takeaways on the value
of design and its role in catalyzing
innovation
and once again i'd like to thank all the
speakers who have graciously offered the
time and effort in making this design
track
come to life and i'm sure it'll be an
inspiring
and illuminating one and with that thank
you
good morning everybody it's a great
pleasure to be here in singapore with
all of you
and today i would love to share with you
a few ideas on sustainability and how we
can all be catalysts for sustainable
impact
in the future so first of all maybe we
can go through a bit what is
sustainability go back to basics and
really define what sociality is and why
it matters
then we can go through the esgs and the
ecosystem that is part of it
all the catalyst opportunities and
solutions that exist
and we can be as well part of them and a
sustainable investment
role that we can all play as well a very
crucial
stakeholder and then a clear and real
example of the un accelerator labs
so if we start really about what is
sustainability and what it truly
why it matters so it is the
this nice combination of connection
connecting environmental and energy
factors
with social issues under governance
concerns
so that is a very beautiful definition
of sustainability but at the same time
we can go deeper as well on uh what is
it really in terms of the ability to
exist constantly
and it refers to this capacity for the
biosphere and human
civilization to coexist great
definitions come as well if we go deeper
in terms of
financial models business models and new
ways of
connecting is as well the people so
connecting all the people
that uh what can make this connection
with the planet itself
how can it co-exist be variable and how
can we as well create sustainable
business models that bring profitability
into the economical
or financial system so that's this
very uh holistic combination of people
planet and a profit that alliance to be
variable equitable and viable
so again is this ability to co-exist and
the word itself says to be able to
sustain itself
in fact this has come you know a long
way since many years ago even 30 years
ago we started all to talk about these
important topics so it was about kind of
climate change
what is it how does it matter then we
started to think yeah it's definitely a
problem
then you know this uh great graphic
explains how
even nowadays 2019 and 20
was like okay is this still thing going
on it's definitely going on
and we are all part of it so let's see
different ideas to be
proactive instead of reactive
so there's a lot of differences where do
we start what is the starting point
what is the time horizon do we start
today
maybe we could have it started earlier
definitely but is that something that we
can wait
there's definitely approach at this
immediately
and as well have this approach to risk
which are the roles of the ecosystem
that all of us we can play
and as well our focus and purpose in the
long term
we know there's a lot of challenges
definitely there's this area of
environmental impact
packaging um as you can see i mean this
happens
everywhere every day safety and toxicity
as well
this product development how we can
define as well what do we consume and
why
we consume it the supply chain
management there's a lot of
interesting initiatives technology can
make definitely that happen today to be
much more sustainable
and how can we be um consuming as well
less energy so all these are challenges
that today we are facing
which are the opportunities and
solutions definitely the raw the
materials to go back to
the energy back to basics what the water
waste
liabilities compliance these are all the
areas that
are part of the solutions and we will
see them in depth afterwards
there's this one important point what's
the truth so there's this perception
in terms of that's you know what people
say is what is sustainability and what
it could be what do we eat what do we
do but then the reality as well we have
to wear in mind and that's something
that
it's connected to you know what we can
see in the picture it's definitely
uh important to understand the truth and
to be
as a consumers uh very mindful of what
do we want to consume
and why there's solutions so we can see
a solution is definitely um the b corp
that's quite advanced in the us now it's
starting to be here as well in asia
but there is like um this stem of
definitely different areas like
environmental workers customers
community governance so there's a score
and this big core they have this
certification
that it's um visible to all the
consumers that's one of many potential
solutions but they're starting
definitely to be out there
very important and crucial area that i
would love to share with you is the esgs
and the ecosystem
es states for environmental social and
governmental
and the environmental sensibility it's
something that it's definitely
at the core or assassin society today
and definitely after covet it has been
enhanced and has been focused
so from everything that we consume we do
we are as well part of this ecosystem so
how regulators and shareholders are part
of these
decision makers how we as consumers
employees of partners and communities
are part of this sensibility and the
civil society
so these are areas crucial social depth
how for example amazing companies like
patagonia have been
very strong in taking action there's all
this sensibility the sincerity the
social part
uh that we are part of that we are in
this
uh environment so how we as a society as
a community
can be part of it and of course the
governmental applications
in um the government so there's
different areas
that they you can comply with um
different regulations
in specific countries like air water
carbon emission waste product safety but
then some others that are very specific
like committee engagement workers and
safety enforcement
and political engagement here in
singapore for example i'm
extremely impressed on the importance
that the government is putting as well
to the esg's
and all the part of sustainability
because it's definitely crucial for the
long-term
uh impact and growth of the country
so that in terms of corporate governance
it's uh
now everywhere everybody's responsible
for that
from the strategic role as well to
operational executional
so sustainability is coming across and
we can see as well in the different
organizational structures that exist in
companies
so we are seeing that digitalization
it's happening as well with
sustainability
there's even great examples on um
unilever procter gamble of course
patagonia we see as well in the luxury
industry like caring
that they're really taking action so
that's admirable and really something
that
we can all be part of and then of course
it depends when you
try to start executing and thinking
about it we can just
you know think okay we wait and see or
think ahead be prepared and really be
mindful of it
other solutions that we can share are
very important
which is how for example we can start
supporting
all the entrepreneurs and startups on
this area so to give
and to share availability of capital for
this early stage
startups as well to define very clear
business models and how
we can monetize and support these
pathways and these corporate development
partners for this capex energy
that is crucial for long-term success
and growth for these
startups and then scale ups then another
very
crucial area is the corporates as we
were saying so how we can connect
the entrepreneurs and startups with uh
of course corporates corporate venturing
is massive now is growing so news new
business models alignment
are in the outsourced to lafayette
universities as well this is
very big area here in singapore as well
supporting on southeast asia with big
universities like
um nus in seattle so there's definitely
a
great role to play from universities
academias and corporate governance
and then on the part of vc or cvc focus
on these
long-term opportunities and then the
part as well on
you know more growth of companies so
from startups to then
on venture capital investment there's
all this area of climate tech
that there's a lot of challenges but
when there's a challenge there's always
an opportunity
so how can we bring as well extend time
to commercialization and exit
how we can bring capital intensity how
can we innovate
and bring a strategic corporate uh
partnerships and
bring a technical assessment and of
course bringing go to market
and new policies to make that happen
so this sustainable investment its role
is very crucial
at every part of the stakeholders so
there are different stakeholders in
different areas of the society
so we are all part of it one of course
is a investment
that's what i'm going to go a bit deeper
on that but as well all the
entrepreneurs all the corporates all the
power of academia and education
and crucial role of the government and
institutions so these
uh five areas of the ecosystem we go a
bit deeper
on all the sustainable investment this
is a massive opportunity
we know is a trillion dollar market if
we bring clean tech software
biotech nowadays uh there's of course
health tech very massive as well so all
the area
of um if we just take health well-being
it's
around six trillion market opportunity
so all this is coming in a good time to
really take action
so therefore there's a big area for
climate as investment opportunity
so this way it's we can make this um
multi-trillion dollar it's a
really once in a century transformation
so now is we are in this
very uh crucial moment in history it's
really this moment
where we can make change happen it's a
moment where we can really connect
technology or you know financial capital
as well with all the human capital
and of course with all the community
capital it's a moment where we can
connect
business with technology humanity and
make it happen so this climate tech this
investment
it's crucial and there's definitely
massive potential and we can invest in
different areas
from this kind of a later stage as well
to make them grow so when we invest in
this part of scale up after the j-curve
it's definitely a moment for investment
and make the companies grow
and then this critical new technologies
and new business models
are completely bring new and created so
how can we
all be part of it different stakeholders
investment is definitely one
but as well in terms of corporate
investment or as well
government investment so there's a lot
of intertwined opportunities
of private and public sector that are
happening
as we speak so it's perfect time in
history
there are some priorities and targets
this is some of many
that we bring here to you but of course
there's
many more we can be part of one is for
example to drive this ambition
systematic
energy efficiency otherwise other ones
are very simple and basic
of today for example the material
efficiency and recycling through greater
value
or as well as channel investment through
the transition higher missing
activities for example today i came with
a bicycle so we all
all can contribute a little even if it's
a small thing
on how we consume for example
plant-based food
or even once or twice a week you know to
have less meat or less fish all these
are very small things that we can all
make to make this
possible we can as well focus on public
and private sector as we
um discussed to really integrate this
support on critical technology targets
foster this value chain collaboration of
all the
ecosystem and stakeholders and as well
the risk the end-to-end pilot
to test new technologies in all this
area of value chain
and then just to finalize i'd love to
share with you a real example that is
happening as we speak
which is the undp accelerator lapse
so the the un it's having this amazing
um
90 centers around the world which their
mission is to speed
and up the learning and execution but
also
they do this searching creating and
sharing new solutions
on the ground so they have this 90
centers around
key cities that are really uh developing
countries that they
find solutions to the biggest problems
they are designed to close the gap
between the current
practices as well of international
development and accelerator
change and then they model these new
capabilities to make
breakthroughs on the areas of inequality
their carbonization for the industrial
revolution and governance
then as um kind of wrap up very
interesting that the accelerated
innovation at the un
and the labs happen this way so first
there's the accelerator labs they have
this
the team that brings expertise and
solution mapping then they network
with the models notes to speed up this
rate of knowledge
they share learning amongst the labs and
then the platform to
execute and to really be on the ground
to find the solutions and then
of course if they work to scale and
bring
returns so the esgs is a very important
focus
uh for the un this disalignment first of
what to invest or not
then the integration of the esg
information to
ensure there's a financial as well
analysis and there's a return
and then how we measure impact so it's
crucial as well that there's
new ways of understanding and measuring
impact so impact can come with new kpis
new okrs
new metrics that really bring these
areas of esgs
they already exist there's many great
universities working on that for example
mit
harbor as well has a center of impact so
all this is happening
so how can we all be part of this and
integrate them
into our ways of studying companies or
being part of a corporate
or of course as investors or anything
related to
academia as well and all the corporate
governance institutions
so this five areas of ecosystem are
crucial
that's why i would love to finalize and
to share with all of you that at the end
we are all responsible
and the best way to predict the future
is really to create it
to create it from today from now to be
part of this ecosystem
we collaborate we co-create we have the
courage to lead
as we follow you know these great
examples
that we can see that are happening we
here in singapore we have a great
government we have a great ecosystem
there's a lot of potential potential
innovation
in bringing technology together with all
the business and humanity
and the investment and the way of being
catalyst for impact is definitely
possible
so let's be all catalysts for impact and
create the future that we
want to be part of thank you
i am julia bonazzi and i am the chairman
and ceo
of aquafield and we make synthetic
fibers
and polymers but actually this is not
the reason why
i am here today i mean not because we
make synthetic fibers and polymers but
it's the way
we make them that is making us very
different
from the rest of the pack and i have to
tell you that when
we started this journey it was very very
bumpy
because i mean when i was trying to
explain
that i wanted to change the nature of my
company
that instead of using oil we wanted to
start from waste
and that for me waste is a very precious
raw materials
at that time it was 2008 bankers
were telling me that i was crazy and
luckily today everything is changing and
everybody's keen
to finance or to belong to the green and
circular economy
even if of course we are just at the
beginning
and why i'm saying that we make
nylon in a very different way because we
developed
a fiber which we sell through the trade
name of economy which is a regenerated
nylon
100 percent recycled and is coming from
plastic
waste such as fishing net fabric scraps
and old carpets and this is quite
different
from the normal production that is
coming from petroleum
based raw materials and this is why we
like to say that equine
is a sustainable infinite and endless
polymer or fiber with a global
warming potential reduction up to 90
percent
in comparison with traditional oil based
raw materials but why
i say that economy is sustainable
because we don't take
any new resource from the planet it is
100 percent
coming from waste and waste particularly
nasty such as
fishiness that we collect from all over
the world
from europe north and south america
asia and even from australia and
new zealand or carpets that are mostly
coming up
from united states and california
plastic scrubs
that we collect in europe and from many
different places
or fabric trains that are coming from
prey consumer production of our
customers that
we bring back through take
back systems that are in place with our
major clients
and the result is not a waste but it's a
series of beautiful products made by the
most
prestigious fashion or carpet companies
around the world
so with nylon you can make jackets you
can make backpacks
you can make raincoats you can make
design works you can make carpets you
can make
many different products
why we say that that econola is infinite
because normally
when we deal with plastic recycling
we normally think of remelting plastic
waste
and this is bringing many limitations
from the aesthetical and from the
performance
point of view well what we have
developed
which is peculiar of very few plastic
polymers is a kind of return
to its original building blocks so we go
back
one step in the chemical chain it is
called the polymerization
and this means that if you give me back
your used carpet
at the end of its life i can regenerate
and give you back the fabric for your
next swimsuit
if you give me back your swimsuit i can
make
the palette to mold your next pair of
sunglasses
and this forever because we have an
efficiency
in the transformation which is close to
100 percent
so it is not like the classical bottle
to fabric
and fabric to grave if you use echo nil
you can
repeat like nature does really forever
and without taking new material from the
planet
and it is really
exactly identical of the nylon
coming from petroleum nothing
more nothing less no differences and
this is why
in this case is not us going to
designers or engineers and saying
what is possible to do but on the
contrary we go there and we say
please do whatever you like express
at the highest level your creativity and
your genius and then you will see that
we will substitute the convention
on iron with our economy because it is
exactly
identical and this is why it is the
preferred choice of
i mean the most important brands
today in the world we collaborate
already
with more than 2000 companies such as
adidas such as prada gucci stella
mccartney
barberry tom dickson brightly i can i
mean repeated two thousand names
but i mean this would take too long so
there is really no limitation
but clearly we are just at the beginning
of our journey and i like to say
that today with economy we can change
the world
but of course we can't do it by
ourselves so
for this reason i always like to say
that we need
three very things we need a proper
legislation we need education of the
population living on our planet and we
need
another important point which is eco
design
why legislation well there are
many examples of so-called extended
producer responsibility which just to
cut the story short
means that every industry should be made
responsible
for the waste and for the raw materials
that they are consuming
from our beautiful planet for example if
you
travel to norway you will see that the
norwegian government is requiring
people making plastic bottles to make
them in a very
particular way the bottle
the corporate the labels everything is
made
thinking at the end of
its use you can do it differently but
you pay a tax
because in this case you are adding cost
to the society
and of course doing this you have to be
responsible of
what you're doing on top of that when
you go
and buy a bottle of water or container
of water from the supermarket or
from the shop you pay a deposit on the
bottle
this is just to encourage to take back
the empty bottles at the end
of its use and
they have also created the collection
points that are making easy to access
the collection of the deposit if you
don't want to go back to the supermarket
because you have no need
going back to that place well the result
is
97 percent of recycling rate
which is of course a clear evidence that
the entire world
can resolve the problem of the plastic
bottles
we for example through economy we could
with the proper legislation and the
proper education and eco-design
resolve entirely the problem of the
carpet waste
which is today more than three percent
of the fraction
of waste sent to landfill in united
states
or the problem of the fishiness which
according to the
united nations is representing around
10 percent of the total plastics that
are damped into the oceans and most
likely
one of the most dangerous fraction
that is contributing to create sadly
famous plastic islands that are floating
into the oceans well
if you make them in 906 and you help us
collecting
we can recycle them all without adding
any cost to the society why education
well not everybody knows that with
better
instruction we create much
more wealth for every society and of
course
also we must consider that we are
around 8 million people or we are
approaching 8 billion people
living in our planet and we need each
single single individual to behave
properly if you really want to change it
it's not
enough that me or you are changing but
we need everybody
to understand and to make how can i say
aware of what is good and what is bad in
order
to have the possibility to make the
right choices
and then eco design eco design is a very
important method because
every product which is today in the
market
is made having linear society in mind so
the take make dispose
system well at this point if we really
want to change
and to make our life easier we need to
redesign
products and systems of distributing
them
in order to be able to collect them and
to create value at the end of their use
for example in the carpetil business
which is a particularly tough product to
recycle
we have a collaboration with one of our
major customers
belonging to the target group that they
are selling
a very performing and beautiful capital
under the trademark of air master
because it's giving better
air indoor quality and also is made
in a way through the collaboration of
the two companies that
each single layer of the carpet tile can
be separated
first of all of course taken back at the
end of use and separated
and recycled when it is the nylon phase
fiber
through the equilibrium regeneration
system and when it is
the echo base backing is recycled
by the carpeting manufacturer who can
return instead of using
materials coming from the planet
using the waste that they have uh
collected
another system to let's say
create products with the circularity
in mind is the mono material concept
and i want to show you one bit
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
in this case i always like to say that
to me
there are two moments in the textile
industry before
my papiery and after number theory
because this beautiful product has been
made
without any compromise in aesthetics
without any compromise
in performances but with a single
material
so the entire jacket is made out of
nine on six or of uh economy so the
fabric outside the linings the material
inside it to give better coherentiation
the zippers the ropes the velcro's
fasteners every the bottoms every single
component is made of nylon six
and the jacket is sold with a qr code
aiming of creating a community of people
who at the end of use but not earlier
than two years said
not to encourage a fast fashion they can
take back the jacket to the shop
and get a credit for the value of the
raw material which is inside
at this point the company will collect
the jackets and send them back
to aqua filler for recycling them
through the economy regeneration
system clearly it is very easy to
recycle this
this product is one single material you
don't have to spend money to separate
into different layers or to create
technologies
for the separation which sometimes are
very difficult
so as i said there are basically two
systems either to design
that are easy to decompose or to design
products that are made with one single
material of course recyclable infinitely
like econo is so let me conclude
with this hope for the future that
we envision a future when people begin
with the end in mind
which means that designers are able to
design products
choosing the right raw materials and the
right way of manufacturing
aiming at the end to recycle them
and engineers the same and of course
consumers have the possibility to choose
among all the beautiful products
available those
that are not creating a problem
but on the contrary representing a
solution
thank you
my name is raghu colley i'm head of
customer centricity
at leapfrog investments
during the course of my work i was
fortunate enough to visit
some of our customers in emerging
markets
there is a couple running a restaurant
on the outskirts of
jakarta who work hard
and their dream is to save up money to
make a pilgrimage
to mecca there's another couple
retired school teachers in sri lanka who
gave tuitions to school children in the
evening
to supplement their pension income
and there's this man a farmer in south
of india
who proudly showed up his various cards
and one of them is the card debit card
with which
he can draw money from an atm he said
he does not feel comfortable going to
the bank because
he looks poor he's illiterate and his
clothes are dirty
and the millions of people like this in
emerging markets
who work very hard and who have dreams
and aspirations
like all affairs they would like to have
their own house
they would like to grow the business
send their children to the university
take care of healthcare needs and become
self-sufficient
in their lifetime it's not easy for them
because it's very difficult to get loans
because they do not have
collaterals or documents and sometimes
most of them do not have and have the
basic insurance
leapfrog was founded 10 years ago to
provide
capital to financial and healthcare
services companies
in southeast asia and sub-saharan africa
who are serving low-income groups
today we have raised over 1.6 billion
dollars in capital
have 29 investments in 10 markets and
our companies together impact the lives
of over 200 million customers
and many of them are these low-income
groups
let me introduce a few of our companies
pasar police is a fintech company
in indonesia they partner with online
services companies
such as tokopedia traveloka and gocheck
to provide
contextual insurance with low premiums
if you're buying a smartphone on
tokopedia you might be offered a screen
protection insurance
at the point of checkout they use
automation
to simplify the process of buying as
well as the process of claiming
for the consumer soft logic is a life
insurance company in sri lanka
and one of the best known they have an
excellent agency network
and they recently launched micro
insurance
for rural areas in partnership with the
postal service
and they also have partnerships with
mobile operators
for micro insurance vora kgfs
is a microfinance company in india
they provide 500 to thousand thousand
dollar loans to
women and rural entrepreneurs
for their various business activities
another company which used to be a
microfinance company has become a bank
two years ago think air they now serve
urban as well as rural customers and
have a wide range of banking services
including digi banking and they serve
almost
2.5 million customers
for us profit for us impact means profit
with
purpose we not only deliver on the
financial returns expected of a private
equity company
but we also deliver on the
impact goals as well
we have our own proprietary methodology
to measure
impact called the firm but a simple and
tangible metric
is essential products and scale
essential products and services at scale
to
emerging consumers our companies
collectively
has delivered millions of loans
and remittances and
as well as savings products
and they've touched the lives of over
200 million customers
and have been cumulatively growing at
the range of at a rate of 54 percent in
terms of customer
breach
why is impact so important for
investment
it's not only does good for the society
but
also provides a tremendous business
opportunity
the millions of customers all in the
emerging markets
with young demography in asia and africa
when someone turns 18 or 20 then to the
job market
they take the first loan or buy the
first insurance product
they buy vehicles they get married they
have children
they send the children to school and
they grow their business
and also take care of the healthcare
needs along the way
they are on a journey from the current
state to become middle class
in their lifetime and in the process
they require many products and services
and which
which provides a tremendous opportunity
for our companies
to serve them and enable them in their
journey to become middle class
companies can maximize the value from
these customers
with a ruthless focus on customers
companies can expand to new markets by
identifying new customer segments
and unmet needs they can drive the
revenue growth
by launching new products and with
extensive
consumer testing it can reduce the cost
of
customer acquisition through digital
marketing companies can enhance
customer experience across all touch
points and increase the loyalty
using data sciences companies can
cross-sell products
and with digital engagement we can
retain customers
and build on brand equity using a
combination of all these levers
we can maximize the profit per customer
this requires cross-functional effort
from various departments
marketing i.t operations products and
strategy it requires orchestration
to support this customer-centric culture
and build capabilities in our companies
an area of customer experience
we've launched a multi-year program
called six launchpad
in this program about 11 companies
are participating and they're all
consumer facing companies
they learn about new methodologies
techniques and tools from
guest speakers as well as internal
expert team in areas
of digital experience customer
measurement customer journey
and other areas they undertake projects
of three to four months duration with a
sharp focus
on improving the customer experience
and we provide guidance and mentoring
for them
during the course of this project as
well as measure the impact on the
business
at the end of the projects
let me share with you a few examples of
this
one of our companies provides micro
insurance
micro enterprise loans to small
businesses in rural india
the company has mapped the customer
journey end-to-end
across for the loan disbursement process
one of the things we've learned
is that it takes almost about eight to
ten years or more for the customer to
get the money
and secondly it requires several visits
by the
loan officers to visit the customer to
obtain documents
or to very fondly of the business for
credit assessment purposes
the company has entirely redesigned the
process and
improved upon the customer credit
assessment
algorithms today the turnaround time for
loan disbursement has come down to four
days from the previous eight to ten days
and they're also able to process more
loans per month
lifro also developed a customer
experience
score measurement and a dashboard and
many of our companies have implemented
this
over 250 to 400 customers are called
every month
for for this score and it is
the dashboard shows a sample for an
insurance company
across all phases of the journey not
only do you get a score for each phase
but also for specific areas within that
particular journey
management monitors this on a monthly
basis and in areas where the score is
low such as
the areas marked in red they take
interventions to fix those
this is much better than waiting for the
survey
at the end of the year and then acting
on it because
you can intervene this on a regular
basis this has a tremendous impact
on many of our companies to improve
their operations
another company my life launched their
micro insurance through ussd a few years
ago
and after more than two years they only
had a few thousand users because the
product was simply difficult to use
on the usb interface
the company has used design experts to
redesign the interface completely
and test it extensively with the
consumers before launching
since the launch a few months ago there
has been tremendous growth and they now
have a more than 200 000 customers
with a month on month growth rate of 37
clearly design had a big impact on the
traction
for customers here
another company in nigeria developed
an app for the customers the previous
version of the app they had had only a
few thousand users after three or four
years of years
using ux design expertise this product
was launched
a few months ago and now they have all
more than 18 000 users
and it has a 4.5 rating on the google
store
every month thousands of customers view
the monthly statements for the pensions
and the transactions history this
reduced the
calls to the customer's support for
these statements which is to happen
previously as you can see from all these
examples
using design to improve the experience
of the customers had a tremendous impact
on the business performance if you're a
financial services company
government agency or any business for
that matter
and want to impact with
experience design here are a few
pointers
based on my journey with the leaf raw
for the last few years
i think first and foremost is to
identify a member of the senior
leadership team
as responsible for the customer
experience customer experience is not
necessarily the responsibility of a
single function in the company it cuts
across
all the company and requires
orchestration therefore
a leadership team member is required for
that
it's absolutely worthwhile to map the
customer journey for all products and
segments in
very detail from the customer point of
view and this will show up
many pain points the customers has which
are not
usually identified in the operational
processes which most companies have
it's very useful to measure customer
experience score on a monthly basis
rather than the end of the year because
it gives an opportunity
to make interventions and
finally i think there are capabilities
companies need to build
in the areas of digital experience
design
data sciences or behavioral sciences
initially it might be helpful to have
consultants helping
but eventually being used to become
internal capabilities
of the company creating
impact is hard work it takes time it
requires
strategic thinking and as investors
we have a long-term view on that
back here in singapore i also eat at the
hawker stalls
like most of the residents of singapore
and i had to withdraw money
from atm to pay at the hawker centers
because most of them
accepted the cash
and recently the government of singapore
along with support from design agencies
and other organizations
have rolled out cashless payment systems
for many of these hawkers who are
older generation who have difficulties
switching to digital platforms
on their own i was very surprised
a few days ago when i went to one of my
favorite talkers
that they have a qr code hanging there
and i could make a cashless payment
clearly experience design not only
impacts
the likelihoods of entrepreneurs like
this but also
the economy as well as the quality of
life
for consumers like me as well
thank you to mark we and the team
at design singapore council for giving
me this opportunity
to share my experiences